now for our daily cancellation we're
going to be shortened to the point here
i'm i'm late on this i admit and part of
me was hesitant to perform this
cancellation because it seems so
redundant i mean why bother canceling
jameel hill
she's already permanently canceled every
day is another cancellable offense from
her
but this one i just can't let go i can't
resist it's the principle of it
so here's the latest from jamil uh a
tweet it says
been reading isabelle wilkerson's new
book cast that's a book about racism in
america i haven't read it don't plan to
uh she says if you were of the opinion
that the united states wasn't nearly as
bad as nazi germany
how wrong you are can't encourage you
enough to read this masterpiece
if jamil hill calls a book a masterpiece
i'll be pretty sure to avoid it but
nearly as bad as nazi germany now
obviously the very fact that you can
even make this statement without being
carted off to a camp somewhere is proof
in and of itself that it's completely
false jamil hill's
entire career at this point is proof
that the statement is false her only
existed her existence is focused around
complaining about america and the
president and telling us how evil our
country is
and she does very well for herself she
makes plenty of money
very comfortable let me ask you how much
money do you think you could make
or could have made in nazi germany if
you went into the business of
criticizing germany and hitler
i mean how prominent and successful do
you think you could have been
some people did in fact do that it
wasn't much of a business
and uh and you know and they had to do
it while they were in hiding and most of
them wound up dead
so this cannot be emphasized enough the
first clue that you are not under a
fascist dictatorship
is that you can go out in public and say
we are under a fascist dictatorship
second clue is that actually in this
country you can do more than that you
can make that statement in the form of
burning a building
or throwing chunks of concrete at police
and you'll probably emerge unscathed you
can go home after a fun night of violent
insurrection
pop some you know leftover chinese into
the microwave watch a little netflix
before bed
this should tell you something about the
level of fascism in america namely that
the level level is
zero unless we're counting you yourself
as
you know the violent bully wreaking
havoc and destruction
as the fascist in which case the level
of fascism in america is
you and you know we could go on for days
here giving other ways in which
modern america differs from nazi germany
because it differs in every conceivable
way
yet jamil hill is an allegedly educated
person saying this
and lots of allegedly educated people
agree
and have said similar so what does that
tell us
it tells us i think the familiar story
first that people in this country
are woefully ignorant of the basic facts
of history
we have reached catastrophic levels of
ignorance
now people in this country they know
some names hitler thomas jefferson
columbus
and of course they put all those people
on the same moral level and they know
some events you know world war
ii 911 uh the moon landing uh the
building of the pyramids you know
the pilgrims were in there somewhere in
between but they have almost
no fleshed out understanding of any of
these people or events
and that's because a fleshed-out
in-depth understanding developing a real
grasp of a subject requires you to do
things like read full entire books
you want to know about the rise of nazi
nazism in germa
germany well read the rise and fall of
the third reich one of the great
non-fiction great history books of all
time in my view
but it's a thousand pages long and a
country full of people who have
melted their brains and destroyed their
capacity for concentration by ingesting
nothing but tv and movies and youtube
videos aren't reading a thousand pages
or even 10 pages
so this is a as i said crisis
catastrophic levels of ignorance that
we're dealing with in america
um and yet
you know p people we would say that we
have
we are maybe the most informed society
in the history of the world
we certainly have access to more
information than
any other society ever has in the modern
world
we have access to really all of the
accumulated
knowledge of mankind we have access to
in these little devices that we carry
around in our pockets
so we have access to a lot of
information we are
most of us very informed in the sense
that
we have a lot of disjointed bits of
trivia and little bits of this and that
bouncing around in our noggins um
but in terms of real understanding and
actual knowledge
of events and things that are occurring
around
us and have occurred in history we don't
have very much of that at all
so that's the first thing second thing
is of course just the
immense amount of privilege
that you have to have that someone like
jameel hill
must have she's a well-known prominent
person i don't know what her net worth
is but
um i can pretty much guarantee you it's
considerably more than the average
person's net worth
and uh as i said she makes a living just
complaining about america and uh
in in in in often in quite absurd
terms very comfortable and yet
she looks at her position in america and
and what she goes through
as equivalent to the persecution of
people under hitler and nazi germany
the the little bit of discomfort that
she faces
you know in her mind it may as well be
getting shipped off to a concentration
camp
because she is so privileged
and it's the same story these rioters
and looters
extremely extraordinarily privileged
people
who encounter a little bit of pushback a
few obstacles
a few things don't go that way in their
lives and they they cannot handle it to
them it is
it is a crisis it is a historic
persecution
it it it puts them you know in the same
category as
as as all of the horrifically oppressed
and persecuted people of history
so that is you want to talk about
privilege there it is right there
that's why jamil hill is of course
cancelled but you know as i said we
should be canceled again tomorrow and we
we could do this any
um and you know so every once in a while
we'll just we'll check in with what your
meal hill is doing and cancel her and
then go about our business
so there it is hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated